nathalie kosciusko morizet est l'invité
de preuves par 3 en cette quatrième
semaine de guerre des chefs à l'ump
bonsoir et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes l'incarnation
féminine des non-alignés et vous
réagirez bien sûr dans un instant au
dernier rebondissement d'une affaire que
françois fillon juge lamentable ça vous
fait au moins un point commun
l'ancien premier ministre se dit prêt à
passer la main pour laisser place à de
nouvelles candidatures c'est peut-être
une idée qui vous plaît enfin vous lirez
dans un instant à frédéric dumoulin de
l' agence france-presse notre partenaire
qui nous rejoindra donc dans un instant
ainsi que perrine tarneaud de public
sénat
on va d'abord parler si vous le voulez
bien du gouvernement le premier sera
dévoilé un ensemble de mesures pour
lutter contre la pauvreté qui gagne on
le sait dans notre pays est ce que
globalement vous avez envie d'approuver
ce dispositif ou de le critiquer je
trouve que il faut pas confondre
l'action politique avec ce qui poussait
trop longs ressemble à une forme de
charité la charité c'est important
l'assistance c'est important le le
soutien ned la solidarité c'est
important mais l'action politique
elle doit rechercher la justice et la
justice quand on est dans la difficulté
la justice quand on a du mal à trouver
sa place dans la société
ça passe par le travail voilà évidemment
il faut pouvoir aider les personnes qui
sont en difficulté on est dans une
société qui laisse pas tomber ce qui est
à un moment mettre le genou à terre moi
je le vis dans ma ville à longjumeau
c'est vrai qu'il ya en ce moment une
augmentation de la pauvreté
c'est vrai qu'avec la crise c'est très
difficile on est un exemple on est en
train d'augmenter chez moi la superficie
l'épicerie sociale pour que tout le
monde et on a de plus en plus de
familles pour que tout le monde puisse
et avoir à manger et quand c'est la
grande difficulté pouvoir avoir des
menus un minimum équilibré par action
pour les enfants jeux d'hiver on a
plusieurs familles donc ça il faut le
faire mais simplement ça ne peut pas
être le coeur d'une politique ça ne peut
pas être l'objet principal d'une
politique parce que dit le premier
ministre
sauf que pour le moment le premier
ministre met ça en avant pour ne pas
faire et ne pas faire ce qu'il faudrait
en matière économique
la première nécessité c'est de trouver
un emploi bien sûr encore une fois on
est dans une société qui laisse tomber
personne mais on résoudra pas les
problèmes seulement en augmentant le rsa
en augmentant les revenus de
l'assistance en oubliant d'ailleurs la
dimension activité qui est prévu dans le
r gens parce que c'est un peu ça qu'il
ya des allées projet le président et
j'ajoute que on le fera ou encore en ce
moment où on est en situation déficit
public d'endettement où l'état n'a plus
d'argent
les mesures qui ont été annoncées par le
premier ministre elles seront chiffrées
entre demi heure et demie hier 5
jusqu'en 2017
voilà je crois que l'argent aujourd'hui
il est utile en réinvestissant dans
l'économie en faisant en sorte de nous
est endetté en faisant en sorte d'aider
les entreprises à créer des emplois
d'améliorer notre compétitivité les
entreprises son front on est en
situation de guerre économique
il ya d'abord l'axé un pacte de
compétitivité en laisse et de 20
milliards d'euros là on parle de 2
milliards pour la solidarité s dont deux
mineurs qui sont mal employé pour vous
franchement je le dis je me franchement
on est en situation où on est en
situation de guerre économique quand on
est en guerre on se demande qui offrons
ceux qui sont froncer les entreprises
c'est elle qui crée des emplois
c'est elle qui in fine et nous permet de
nous sortir de la crise
vous dites il ya un plan de
compétitivité de 20 milliards bon la
réalité c'est que il ya plusieurs
dizaines de milliards de nouveaux impôts
qui ont été mis sur les entreprises
depuis que ce gouvernement est arrivé
votre jour il y avait une interview du
patron d'axa il disait voilà dans ma
société
tous les nouveaux impôts créé par le
gouvernement ces 176 millions d'euros en
plus 176 millions d'euros en plus que ça
va nous coûter bon et j'ai commencé à
calculer leurs crédits d'impôt donc avec
un an de décalage en fonction des
calculs
réunis à gavin à gaz peut-être que ça
nous rendre à 20 millions d'euros
donc ce que le gouvernement présente
comme un plan en faveur de la
compétitivité
en fait c'est du rattrapage sur une
forte baisse de compétitivité
bien bien plus bien plus profonde que ce
rattrapage pour certaines entreprises et
simplement moi je dis toutes ces mesures
je juge pas telle ou telle mesure je dis
que ça ne peut pas être un projet pour
la france ça ne peut pas être un projet
sur les français vous y voyez une
incitation à l'assistanat est souvent
dénoncée vous iriez jusqu'à l'ain c'est
qu'on a un problème en france de rapport
entre les revenus de l'assistanat et les
revenus du travail entre la difficulté
qui a trouvé un travail tout ce qu'il ya
comme et fait clic et tout ce qu'on perd
comme support quand on trouve un travail
ce constat alors si je peux reprendre
ses transports et belle saison en force
chacun peut le comprendre
si on augmente un peu les revenus
d'assistanat si on fait pas ce qu'il
faut pour soutenir le travail
regardez on regarde juste juste la
logique on a supprimé la défiscalisation
des heures sup pour des millions de nos
compatriotes sont des revenus en moi
sont plusieurs centaines d'euros en
moins à l'année donc ça c'est des
revenus du travail en moins sont des
personnes qui continuent avec leur
travail vont tous chinois et en face on
augmente en proportion différente est
revenue d'assistanat donc vous voyez
bien qu'on modifie les équipes dans un
sens qui moi ne me semble pas le
meilleur équilibre pour la france pour
l'avenir de la france
l'avenir des français ne peut pas être
dans l'assistance sociale mais dans le
travail et que pensez vous d'un mot de
la création d'une garantie jeunes sous
la forme d'un contrat d'un an avec les
là également le versement regarder
l'ensemble du plan il ya des choses dont
je peux dire que je les trouve
individuellement intéressant de vous et
de lune que j'ai regarder d'un peu plus
près c'est là la question de tous ces
gens qui ont droit au rsa complément
d'activité de ce sont des gens qui
travaillent mais qui sont ce qu'on
appelle les travailleurs pauvres et
gagne pas beaucoup il au droit un petit
complément de la part du rsa ils sont
très nombreux
le savoy rappel touche 68 % du don le
plan on dit bon on va mieux les informer
je trouve ça intéressant le rsa dans sa
partie complément d'activité en plus qui
possèdent ce qu'ils retrouvent un
travail elle est intéressant donc je
vous dis pas que tout est achetée dans
ce monde là c'est pas ça c'est vraiment
que ça n'est pas l'objet d'une politique
en soi si je voulais prendre les images
je dirais que on a besoin d'un
gouvernement chirurgien on a besoin de
réformes de fond on a besoin se
transformer pour faire face à cette
cette concurrence très dur qui est celle
de la mondialisation dans la crise et en
face de ça on a un gouvernement
rebouteux qui nous fait des décoctions à
base d'assistance
parfois on peut être tenté d'aller voir
un rebouteux et on sait bien que les
maladies de fond on les soigne pas comme
ça la france ne trouvera pas son salut
dans ce type de la compétition on
retiendra l'image alors un gouvernement
de rebouteux et non pas de chirurgien
vous avez cité monsieur de castres le
patron d'axa il ya un instant mais je ne
sais pas et comment évolue son salaire
mais on a découvert aujourd'hui dans le
même temps qu'eux on dresse le constat
de la précarité de la pauvreté qui
progresse dans notre pays que les
patrons du cac 40 continue d'augmenter +
4 % l'an prochain l'an dernier comment
est-ce que vous réagissez comme jacques
j'ai toujours pensé et ça fait longtemps
qu'on le pense que la proposition qui
était celle de faire entrer plus de
représentants des salariés dans les
conseils y compris dans les conseils de
rémunération qui fixe la rémunération
était une bonne proposition
ces choses là dans un système qui sont
complètement transparent dans un système
dans lequel on peut parler de la
répartition des bénéfices des profits à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise devienne
soit impossible insupportable et ne se
font pas soit elle trouve du sens parce
que c'est un patron qui a très bien
réussi et qui a apporté de la de la
richesse et du développement pour passer
pas toujours le cas mais c'est contre
nature sont pas toujours fondées moyens
voilà un mot sur l'exil fiscal de gérard
depardieu ce qu'il vous choquent un
certain c'est tellement dommage parce
que bon on avait astérix et obélix donc
les astérix est parti à londres
obélix par bruxelles ceci dit on peut on
peut on peut s'interroger sur un système
fiscal qui conduit en masse à ce genre
de départ parce qu'au delà des cas
individuels
il ya un moment qui se fait qui est un
mouvement qui qui doit nous interroger
qui ne veut pas de député socialiste
suggère la déchéance de nationalité si
les exilés fiscaux ne paye plus d'impôts
en france
qu'est ce que vous en pensez c'est
réaliste souhaitable et réalisable
enfin c'est toujours le problème il ya
l'effet qu'il plaît pas aux socialistes
et donc il voudrait supprimer en quelque
sorte s'est fait faire en sorte que ça
n'existe pas est ce que il faut pas se
poser la question de savoir pourquoi
tout le monde pas et je vous dirais que
moi ce qui m'inquiète le plus c'est pas
des personnes qui partent pour des
motifs fiscaux
évidemment ça doit interroger sur une
fortune déjà réalisés
c'est tous ces jeunes qui partent qu'ils
se disent c'est pas en france qu'est mon
avenir parce que dans les dernières
mesures qu'a prises le gouvernement
ilias a comme conséquence il ya ceux qui
partent c'est vrai c'est une réalité il
ya ceux qui partent parce qu'ils ont de
l'argent et qu'ils se disent qu'ils vont
trop payés en proportion de leurs
revenus et qui se met à l'abri
fiscalement mais il ya aussi toute cette
génération qui se dit c'est pas en
france que je vais créer mon entreprise
parce que avec le nouveau système de
taxation des plus-values de cessions
notamment dans le milieu du numérique
moi je vois ça j'ai été secrétaire
d'état au numérique je connais bien ce
milieu c'est pour une pige ont été
entendues ces des personnes moyennement
parce que vous savez les conditions qui
ont été mises par le gouvernement il
faut rester disant être sont des
conditions qui correspond pas
l'industrie du numérique
parce que dans l'industrie du numérique
les gens vendent et achètent très
rapidement ce sont des boîtes qui tourne
très très vite
c'est ça le monde du net et et façon le
gouvernement a fait semblant d'entendre
en créant de nouvelles niches des
nouvelles conditions c'est encore à
l'assaut du réinvestissement français
laissez moi ce que je voudrais c'est
qu'on a un système fiscal qui est
organisée autour de l'idée que quand on
prend des risques
quand on investit quand on crée des
emplois
on est on est on doit être soutenu d'une
manière ou d'une autre
moi je voudrais un système qui soit
reconstruit autour d'une notion que j'ai
portée que j'ai développé dans mon
mouvement poétique que j'appelle la
réciprocité faire en sorte qu'on ne
puisse pas donner donner donner au
système sans recevoir ou recevoir
recevoir toujours sans donner et
j'applique ce principe de réciprocité de
la même manière à la question du rsa
je pense qu'il faut pas éternellement
pouvoir recevoir sans donner c'est
l'intérêt par exemple en face d'un
revenu d'assistance de mettre des heures
minimum de travail d'intérêt général de
participation à l'activité avoir avoir
une forme de donnant gens demanderont
jamais pareil et c'est pareil pour les
entreprises une entreprise qui crée de
l'activité créé d'emplois une start-up
une entreprise en formation il faut pas
qu'elle ait l'impression que tout ce que
le monde politique et le gouvernement a
à lui dire c'est qu'on va on va on vous
reconnaît pas dans votre boutique ses
deux créateurs d'emplois et on va vous
prendre à leur hameau de mot encore sur
des affaires de justice j'aimerais vous
entendre nathalie kosciusko morizet sur
le fin de la saga judiciaire et politico
médiatique qui oppose l dsk à nafissatou
diallo la transaction nancy il y en
ad'autres on va parler de celle de dans
un instant café judiciairement son
approche
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la façon
dont la page est tournée moi quand c'est
un système fils hier américain s'est pas
parlé du site me suis dit que je ne
ressens pas je ne porte pas de jugement
sans retour mais j'aurais concours a le
jeu pour pas jument système judiciaire
américain mais comme beaucoup de
français c'est je suis surprise de la
manière dont ça fonctionne ça fonctionne
pas du tout comme chez nous et c'est
vrai que ça ça renvoie une image un
sentiment qui est un peu curieux parce
que chez nous en france d'un système
judiciaire c'est pas ça qu'on attend de
la justice si vous voulez on attend de
la justice qu'elle dise quelle tranche
ce qui s'est passé ce qui s'est passé
donc cette cette méthode de transactions
et de transaction autour de compensation
financière est quelque chose qui nous
surprend et qui lui une certaine manière
nous choque bon c'est la tutelle
judiciaire
encore une fois pas de jugement et pas
porter de jugement sur le système
judiciaire à l'étranger souvent fait
quand même
on comprend pas bien quoi est-ce que
vous avez cinq mois j'attends de la
justice
est-ce que vous et j'attends juste
choquée de voir françois hollande
envoyer des explications manuscrite à la
justice pour dénoncer des mensonges et
appuyé à la plainte de sa compagne à
propos des auteurs de sa biographie la
frondeuse je dirais que moi je suis
choqué du manque de cohérence et vous
donner deux exemples sur ce sujet bond à
beaumont à cette fameuse affaire du
tweet
et puis valérie trierweiler dit mme je
ne ferai plus politique et puis plein
finalement elle reçoit les opposants au
projet notre dame des landes
donc après avoir taclé ségolène royal
pendant la campagne législative par un
tweet
eh ben c'est un drôle de message qu'elle
envoie jean marc ayrault qui le premier
soutien au projet de notre dame des
landes problème de cohérence politique
on fait la politique ont fait pas de
politique et là françois hollande à son
tour et dans un problème de cohérence il
a dit pendant la campagne présidentielle
il en a fait une une marque en quelque
sorte vous savez c'était cette fameuse
tirade mois président qui ne se mêlerait
pas des affaires judiciaires des
affaires personnelles et qu'il envoie
une lettre dans un procès en donc en
diffamation pour pour pour pour
témoigner pour dénoncer obligations
france mais s'il avait dit pendant la
campagne présidentielle
je considérerai que quand on s'attaque à
ma personne ou à celle de ma compagne
sais pas ce qu'il a dit il a dit le
contraire il a dit moi président je
m'investirai absolument pas dans quoi
que ce soit au niveau personnel je vous
dis c'est pas une intervention
personnelle
c'est juste que ça le touche directement
enfin c'est encore plus personnel encore
plus personnel donc la société cercueil
mais le problème de cohérence et on a
l'impression que ce gouvernement
n'arrive pas à tenir et ce président
n'arrive pas à tenir une position plus
de moi et je vais pas mais les
politiques finalement je m'emmêle mois
président je ferais pas ça finalement je
le fais on a l'impression que la ligne
mais c'est pas qu'elle n'est pas clair
c'est que tout tout peut-être née dans
les deux mois qui suit alors à parler de
l'ump maintenant si vous voulez bien et
de la perspective d'un nouveau
tout le monde s'accorde sur le principe
mais tout le monde se dispute sur la
date
avant d'accueillir frédéric dumoulin
donc de l' agence france-presse il ya
beaucoup de questions sur le sujet pour
vous bien sûr on fait le point sur le
front aujourd'hui avec sophie normand 4e
semaine de crise à l'ump toujours pas
d'accord entre les deux belligérants
ce n'est pas faute de multiplié les tête
à tête
jean françois copé et françois fillon
sont désormais à leur cinquième
rencontre des rencontres toujours
organisés selon le même rituel à huis
clos à l'assemblée nationale tantôt dans
le bureau de l'un tantôt dans le bureau
de l'autre des mises en scène qui ne
débouchent sur rien les deux
protagonistes ne veulent pas lâcher
leurs morceaux sont aussi accrochés l'un
que l'autre
fillon par une espèce de fureur de ce
qui s'est passé et copé qui est arrivé à
remporter cette élection interne au
parti et qui veut pas lâcher parce qu'il
sait que sur comment sans doute y perdra
les deux hommes se heurtent sur la
question de la date pour organiser un
nouveau scrutin
pour françois fillon il doit avoir lieu
avant les élections locales prévues en
2014 et 2015
françois fillon qui vient de lâcher du
lest et fixe une nouvelle date butoir à
l'été 2013
pas question pour jean françois copé qui
campe sur ses positions rien ne se fera
avant les municipales de 2014
une crise sans précédent qui débouche
sur l'effondrement dans les sondages de
la cote de popularité des deux
protagonistes
une crise qui n'aura pourtant eu aucune
répercussion sur le premier tour des
législatives partielles de ce dimanche
où les candidats de l'ump se sont
facilement qualifiés il n'y a pas eu de
catastrophe électorale lors des
élections partielles
loin de là ça produit cet effet pervers
que la situation profondément anormal
que vit ce parti peut-être considéré au
fond comme presque supportable et ça
retarde d'autant l'issue de la crise en
cours beaucoup craignent que ce dialogue
de sourds ne conduisent un statu quo
durable avec un jean françois copé
président contesté du parti et en
françois fillon président d'un groupe
ump dissident
un statu quo que n'accepte pas les
parlementaires l'ancien président de
l'assemblée nationale bernard accoyer
organisera mardi prochain une
consultation de tous les parlementaires
élus sous l'étiquette ulb pour ou contre
la tenue d'une nouvelle élection du
président du parti avant l'été 2013
voilà fabrique des moules est avec nous
au bon soir frédéric vos questions à la
non alignés nathalie kosciusko morizet
oui justement je sais que vous n'aimez
pas trouvé l'expression non alignés mais
bon à faire avec entend trouver une
autre ça fait ça fait 23 jours
maintenant que l'élection ait lieu et on
est toujours quasiment au même point
c'est une situation de crise à l'ump
à l'instant t comment vous voyez l'issue
quand est-ce que vous là quel est le
deadline pour vous quel est le vraiment
la date butoir votre constat oui on est
toujours dans leur âme mais mais les
choses sont pas exactement
dans la même situation qu'il ya trois
semaines et notamment l'idée de revoter
elle a progressé et l'eau ou veux j'en
suis très satisfaite c'est une idée que
j'ai lancée de mercredi
attendez si j'ai lancé le mercredi c'est
jugeant être bord d'un pardon je suit la
concurrence juste après le vote
bon c'était déjà évident que appartement
où il y avait un problème de légitimité
et ben on se tournait vers ceux qui
tiennent l'origine de la légitimité
entre leurs mains qui sont les militants
et à ce moment là c'était c'était loin
de faire l'unanimité ou même la majorité
il n'y avait pas c'était une des kippas
rsa et puis l'idée a bien progressé
j'ai lancé une pétition puis quarante
mille personnes là ont signé cette
pétition une pétition c'est au tour de
mon existence et pas forcément des
vitriers oxygéner le temps aussi
c'est beau féminin veut parce que oui
mais j'ai diffusé à travers un reportage
où il y avait des gens de gauche a
décidé j'ai diffusé à travers des
réseaux et des mails mi temps alors
qu'ils aient des personnes quelques
soins qu'ils se soient amusés à le
signer vous savez ça c'est comme les
primaires socialistes
vous avez quelques personnes mais bon
c'est la majorité écoutez c'est pas
l'objectif
ces objectifs c'est tout simplement de
donner un support à tous ces militants
qui sont très nombreux à dire nous
voulons revoter nous gâte les jours vous
pourriez d'après après on appelait dans
les fédérations à faire des assemblées
générales de fédérations ou de
circonscription pour que les militants
puissent exprimer cette position que moi
je crois est majoritaire dans le parti
qui le dira qu'une solution c'est de
revoter avec bruno le maire on a créé un
groupe de parlementaires
on a lancé une tribune un appel pour
pouvoir appeler au vote
et l'idée dur vote elle a fait son
chemin au début au début d'année pas
qu'ils sont écoutés j'observe que du
côté de françois fillon
il en a fait sa proposition ce matin du
côté de jean-françois copé
il en parle lui maintenant alors certes
à une échéance plus lointaine des
municipales mais ils ont foncé question
n'est plus le cas au début parce que je
voulais juste moduler votre propre nom
qu'on vit depuis trois semaines ce faire
non de trois semaines donc l'horizon
idéal ses coins et pour moi et pour moi
tout passe forcément par leur vote et
cordes à dire attendez je vais à dire
que le nom là dessus donc quand même le
dire ça n'est pas faire débat sur les
responsabilités des uns ou des autres
moi je m'en moque des responsabilités
des envies je veux pas savoir si c'est
l'un qui a commencé ou l'autre qui a
commencé ça n'a aucun intérêt c'est
derrière nous c'est n'aime pas le sujet
le sujet c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans une situation absurde et même un
peu dramatique on a des parlementaires
qui ont été élus sous la même étiquette
pour porter les mêmes valeurs avec la
même mission qui est de s'opposer à haut
pouvoir socialiste qui est de proposer
une alternative une autre espérance pour
les français qui sont en deux groupes
séparés
moi je demande la réunification de ce
héros on a une direction à la tête du
parti qui est contesté avec une élection
qui est considéré par beaucoup comme
douteuse
on m'a je demande on a r'trouvé la
légitimité auprès des militants et
qu'une élection soit faite et que
l'élection doit se faire avant l'été
vous dire avant les troubles pour soi
parce que et le plus vite possible ou
bien si elle pouvait être fait
ces trois semaines que je milite pour
l'élection car pour moi le plus vite
possible c'est le mieux le jeu le plus
vite et le mieux pourquoi avant l'été de
toute façon parce que l'été c'est la fin
de la session ordinaire
je pense qu'à l'issue de cette session
ordinaire le divorce entre les deux
groupes au parlement sera en quelque
sorte consommer pardon dippach parlons
de son mais avant ça il est pardon pour
nos téléspectateurs c'est un tout petit
peu technique mais je m'attarde là
dessus aujourd'hui il ya deux groupes
séparés mais c'est une séparation à
moitié les députés sont encore mélangé
dans l'hémicycle les bureaux sont
mélangés bon il ya des débuts dans bouge
dans un des groupes mais tout ça est
absurde pour moi complètement absurde
mais c'est une demie séparation ont fait
ont fait chambre à part dans la même
maison enfin vous voyez c'est bon à la
fin de la session ordinaire
maxime les choses seront complètement
clos quasiment mois de juin et on a
entendu ce matin mais j'avoue possible
et monsieur fillon a dit lui-même que ça
pourrait être donc ouvert à d'autres
candidatures que le duel auquel on
n'avait pas ce que vous avez essayé
d'être candidate au mois de septembre
vous n'avez pas eu dans le temps imparti
les parrainages nécessaires
est ce que vous serez candidate je ne
sais pas du tout et je vais vous dire ce
n'est pas la priorité la priorité c'est
pas les questions de personne c'est de
se mettre d'accord sur le principe et la
date d'une élection
moi je les dis pour moi tout vaut mieux
que la situation actuelle
si les deux protagonistes se mettaient
d'accord sur six se mettaient d'accord
seulement sur un nouveau vote entre deux
je sais que ça plaît pas la majorité des
bétons qui souhaite un nouveau vote qui
soient ouverts d'autres candidats mais
je dis même un nouveau vote entre deux
c'est mieux que la situation a créé
aujourd'hui un énorme problème de
légitimité
aujourd'hui il ya urgence à unifier les
groupes donc donc ce qui est important
pour moi c'est de se mettre d'accord sur
un nul serait plus ça quand même qu'il
ya une troisième candidature au moins ou
plus qu'une troisième dans ce cas là si
les cils et les candidatures sont
ouvertes moi j'ai toujours dit ce le mal
que je pensais d'un duel un duel c'est
c'est un affrontement qui est forcément
car ils vous le serez on verra bien on
n'en sait rien on sait même pas quelles
sont les conditions dans lesquelles un
autre organisme n'a aucune activité
michel fau durée pour vos parrainages à
doit être facile avec les la pétition
que vous avez engagé un mot sur les
parrainages
vous savez ce qu'il ya dans les statuts
de l'ump c'est qu'il faut 3% des
militants qui parraine pour se présenter
il n'y a pas écrit qu'il faut demander
la photocopie recto verso de la carte
d'identité qu'il faut le faire en plein
mois d'août et qu'il faut gens
remplissent ce numéro 2 la canadien ont
posé problème
film eric si on fait en envoyant un
bulletin de parrainage et toulouges
adhérents et c'est beaucoup plus facile
ce que je veux dire c'est que il faut
pas confondre les problèmes de principe
et les modalités des modalités c'est
tout à fait d'accord sur les principes
on trouvera les bonnes que ce soir même
donc françois fillon jean françois copé
se revoient pour la cinquième fois leur
fameux tête à tête avec l'eau est ce que
vous leur fait encore confiance pour
arriver à un accord ou pas est ce que
vous pensez être encore financier
remontant pour exiger un accord
bon c'est un passionné de plongée mais
moi je fais confiance aux militants mais
vous avez lancé une pétition
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas un appel
qui étaient restés à la wah loh d'abord
c'est une pétition à l'attention des
militants un support proposé aux
militants pour que les militants
puissent exprimer leur déception et pour
certains leur collègue qu'il arrive si
vous obtenez le fameux vol je crois que
ils sont ils font tous les jours la
démonstration qu'on a raison de leur
faire confiance et qui sont formidables
d'abord je vous fais remarquer un truc
dont il a envie de ça non le limitant
hills en développant nos militants ils
se sont déplacés en masse pour
l'élection pour s'employer
attendez vous avec dans une élection
normale le bureau de vote il est dans la
cantine du groupe scolaire à côté de là
il ya un bureau de vote par
circonscription ça veut dire que dans
les circonscriptions rurales les
militants ils ont fait plusieurs
dizaines de kilomètres en voiture dans
chaque sens et donc non seulement ils
sont déplacés en masse mais depuis il
nous lâche pas c'est pas vrai qu'il ya
des renvois de cartes en masse des
choses comme ça ni il ya quelques
mouvements il ya de la colère bien sûr
qu'il ya la colère mais les militants
expriment la colère dans les assemblées
générales de ce qu'ils exigent il exige
que les choses changent et regardez ce
qui s'est passé aux dernières partielles
les électeurs les électeurs ne se sont
pas détournés
les électeurs nous ces neuf familles
pour justement en revanche que vous
n'avez pas répondu vraiment là-dessus
est ce que vous pensez que les
duellistes sont tous les deux encore
légitime
est ce qu'ils peuvent encore prétendre à
diriger le parti l'un comme l'autre oui
mais
j'ai confiance en eux ou pas mais moi je
n'ai pas choisi je n'ai pas choisi
d'être dit d'ailleurs si j'avais écouté
si j'avais choisi si j'avais adhéré
contre un clan mais si j'avais à dire et
complètement à la ligne de l'un ou de
l'autre
j'aurais été chez l'un ou chez l'autre
je n'y ai pas été donc cette question
j'ai déjà répondu pendant la campagne je
ne me reconnais entièrement ni dans la
ligne de l'un dit dans la ligne de
l'autre voilà je me reconnais
entièrement unes dans les autres et
sonne et ça n'a pas changé depuis
qu est ce que j ce serait quand même un
miracle que les événements des trois
dernières semaines et améliorer sa
nature selon vos la députée laure de la
raudière d'inquiétude non alignés comme
vous disais hier soir que quoi qu'il
arrive que vous obteniez ou pas une
élection elle ne quitterait jamais le
groupe ump vous c'est votre cas vous ne
quitterait jamais le groupe ump est ma
famille politique
donc vraiment et je milite et je milite
pour la réunification des groupes jeu si
j'avais dû ci avait dû quitter rejoint
le rmp
je vais me procurer que ça veut rien
dire si vous voulez et vous verrez si si
s'il se passe des choses fausses
on sait rien mais où l'ump c'est ma
famille politique moi je quitte pas ma
famille politique je veux la transformer
de l'intérieur
je veux qu'elle soit fidèle à elle même
je voudrais dire un mot à écouter cette
famille politique elle est là le
regroupement de différentes sensibilités
de droite parmi lesquels et jose jeudi
au premier rang desquels le goal ispahan
au premier rang desquels parce que c'est
un peu ma famille politique aussi un
gaullisme enfin en tout cas aucune de
ces sensibilités là ne peut se
satisfaire de voir aujourd'hui et
notamment pas la sensibilité gaulliste
de voir aujourd'hui le parti livrer à ce
qu'il ya de pire dans le système des
partis et le système des assemblées vous
souvenez quand même des prises de
position du général de gaulle sur le
système des partis et sur la politique
des assemblées nommé vous rendez compte
alors là on en est à créer deux groupes
parlementaires facelly mais c'est
important de conception mais c'est
important que ce que pourtant je
tel aviv le pompiste singles sont
bienvenues sur ce plateau y en aura
d'autres après mettez la directrice de
campagne de nicolas sarkozy
j'ai été sa porte par sa porte parole
pendant excusez moi est ce que vous
souhaitez qu'il intervienne à nouveau
dans cette crise ou alors que je crois
qu'il faut respecter les choix de
nicolas sarkozy
bon ceci dit qu'on a recours légaux
écoutez je pense qu'il faut respecter
les choix de nicolas sarkozy je le redis
nicolas sarkozy elle a choisi d'être en
réserve de sa famille politique et
auteur ça vaut pas mieux ça n'a pas
vraiment été suis l'un et la peau n'est
pas intervenu publiquement attendait il
pas intervenu publiquement il a choisi
de briller publiquement et je trouve que
le faire parler
malgré lui c'est un peu le faire parler
contre il voulu parler fréquemment vous
bon mais je ne fais pas parler sans son
accord vous avez justement parce que
j'ai été sa porte parole
je respecte sa parole c'est lui qui
choisit quand il veut intervenir mais
c'est pas aux uns ou aux autres de faire
à sa place
merci trader est ici bien voilà perrine
tarneaud arrive maintenant
va prendre votre place chers confrères
cette agence france presse
juste après cette lecture de
l'enlisement à l'ump par sandra
cerqueira et signe faisait votre affaire
d'une certaine manière nathalie
kosciusko morizet oui recalé sur la
ligne de départ en novembre dernier
faute de parrainages mais peut être
remise en selle lors d'un possible vote
de rattrapage ce serait une belle
revanche pour nathalie kosciusko morizet
la guerre des chefs à l'ump lui offre
une belle opportunité une tribune
inattendue son entourage croulerait sous
les appels des fédérations les militants
les cadres des parlementaires aussi
cherchent des personnalités pour animer
les réunions qui parle simplement sans
agressivité vis-à-vis des deux
protagonistes mais qui propose un
discours de sortie de crise et mataly
incarne beaucoup cette personnalité là
c'est la loi de la survie de notre
famille politique
celle qui nous sort par le haut du
conflit dans lequel on s'enlise alors
nkm se verrait-elle en sauveuse de l'ump
c'est elle qui est entré en politique il
y à peine dix ans à aujourd'hui les
sondages avec elle
fillon et copé sont en chute libre mais
la députée de l'essonne gagne 4 points
et fait figure de rescapé auprès des
militants sauf qu'elle n'est pas la
seule à la tête des non-alignés
il y à aussi bruno le maire un autre
quadra qui veut lui aussi compté c'est
simplement
façon de dire à plusieurs il ya pas
connaître aliments il ya d'autres
députés autour il ya des sénateurs il ya
72 députés consignes et rappelle l
quarantaine qui ont signé notre tribune
si on ne peut pas se résigner à la
division le maire cossu sco leurs
profils sont trop proches ils ne
devraient pas être des alliés de
toujours
d'autant que l'ancien ministre serait
trop ambitieuse elle avait décidé de ne
pas choisir entre les deux candidats et
pourtant dès que jean françois copé
s'est déclaré vainqueur
nkm l'a appelé un coup de fil pour
demander la tête du conseil national de
l'ump le parlement du parti
une offre de service un peu trop
précipité si on commence à penser que le
mouvement entre guillemets de
non-alignés c'est justement là encore je
me répète qu'une troisième voie
l'emportent sur les deux premières on
aura tous plantés ça marchera pas le
seul point qui peut faire fonctionner
mosson bat-il cette ligne c'est de
considérer qu'elle est désintéressé
beaucoup conseillent à nathalie
kosciusko morizet de maître pour
l'instant c'est ambition entre
parenthèses
mais ses ambitions elle dit les assumer
et la présidentielle de 2017
elle y penserait déjà voilà vous avez
fait on vous a vu faire ça sur le sujet
je tiens mon téléphone portable à votre
disposition jean françois copé m'a
appelé le dimanche soir tard pour me
dire qu'il était ému et c'était
formidable
moi je dormais parce que il était passé
une heure du matin on s'est fait plus
rêver cdp et le lundi soir à nouveau
pour me dire qu'ils souhaitaient moins
rapidement c'est donc à sa demande que
je les rencontre et au siège de l'ump
et c'est absolument faux que j'ai
que j'ai fait une ou deux occasions et
je sais pas du tout j'ai accepté aucune
offre et sait très bien d'où vient ce
truc là il vient d'une discussion que
j'ai eue avec jean pierre raffin donc
elle jean pierre afin me disait il faut
absolument que tu rentres dans l'équipe
et je lui ai dit en riant
et on imagine bien que si j'avais voulu
ce poste c'est pas à la personne qui
devait l'avoir jean-pierre afin comme
l'aurait demandé
je lui ai dit en riant mais apparemment
le jean pierre le seul taux ce qui
pourrait m'intéresser c'est le tien ce
qui est une façon évidemment de le
refuser
j'aurais pas demandé le poste à la
personne qu'il avait bon et on sait bien
en revanche on voit bien comment ce
genre de petites saloperies et balancé
pour essayer de décrédibiliser le
mouvement qu'on a créé par ailleurs avec
bruno le maire qui est un mouvement qui
est indépendant voilà il ya des gens qui
la gêne il ya des gens que ça gêne qui
est des députés indépendants
il ya des gens que ça gêne qui est des
personnes autonomes il ya des gens que
ça gêne que j'ai lancé une pétition qui
recueille aujourd'hui plus de 40 mille
signatures pour appeler à une région
alors qui a barrel des noms mais c'est
vous qui savez qu'ils disent ce genre de
choses fausses parce que c'est à vous
qu'on les dit pas moi mais elle des gens
que génèrent ces jeunes que d'autres et
des ambitions quand même ambition il
revient souvent dans votre papier
moi je comprends pas très bien comment
il est tourné votre papier ou dit mais
vous dites voilà ils ont créé un
collectif mais ils se ressemblent trop
ça va pas durer mais vous l'avez vous
même revendiqué mais aussi refaire votre
ambition ne ferait pas forcément n'est
gagné 1,9 à son ambition dans la vie
c'est très positif dans deux langues
dans la vie il faut avoir de l'ambition
dans la vie mais ce que j'aime pas c'est
la façon c'est horrible ils se
ressemblent sont ou pas et bruno le
maire et moi et vous dites ils se
ressemblent trop ils vont pas pouvoir
sentant montant pas si j'entrais de
villevieux dire ils ont le même profil
et ils vont forcément être concurrents
un moment ou un autre
peut-être de l'hôte être un jour mais
aujourd'hui on a eu en fait pendant
cette campagne pour la présidence de
l'ump
les mêmes options qui ont été de ne pas
prendre parti ni pour un candidat ni
pour l'autre et on est depuis plusieurs
semaines à travailler ensemble pour
essayer de créer un mouvement pour
trouver une solution une solution qui
permette soin de mettre d'accord l'un ou
l'autre soit en dépit de l'un ou de
l'autre d'imposer le point de vue des
militants qui est majoritairement pas le
compte séparé réunification des groupes
et un nouveau vote
est ce que la crise de l'ump aujourd'hui
est la conséquence de l'absence
d'inventaire du quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy
ainsi très c'est une bonne question je
crois pas que la crise soit la
conséquence de l'absence de débat ou à
dire c'est pas vraiment l'absence des
bas je pense en revanche que il était
normal il était logique après une
défaite à l'élection présidentielle que
nous vivions une période de difficultés
c'était normal si vous voulez c'est
après l'impression qu'on a mis un espèce
de couvercle sur le quinquennat de
nicolas sarkozy et que ce droit
d'inventaire ne pouvait pas s'exercer
vous avez des peu nombreux dire même
presque peu nombreuse avec roselyne
bachelot a critiqué notamment la
campagne de nicolas sarkozy en campagne
elle est la dérive un peu populiste sous
l'oeil mais sur le linge suis pas du
tout d'accord avec sa première je crois
c'est pas du tout la même chose le
premier conseiller ça veut dire quoi il
y avait plusieurs conseillers moi il y
avait un conseiller avec lesquels
j'étais en désaccord
je trouve d'ailleurs qu'on donne dans
les médias beaucoup trop d'importance
aux différents conseillers
il y avait un conseiller avec lequel
j'étais en désaccord et j'ai eu
l'occasion dans des dans des petits
cercles ou lire parfois à nicolas
sarkozy la ligne de nicolas sarkozy
n'était pas celle d'un seul des
conseillers la force de nicolas sarkozy
c'est une synthèse c'est une synthèse
entre des valeurs de droite très très
assumé des valeurs de droite qui sont
forts le travail
l'autorité la responsabilité et puis un
esprit de réforme une énergie une
capacité parfois faire à faire exploser
les cadres ordinaire
à les dépasser à ne pas se laisser
enfermer dans le politiquement correct
qui a fait je crois
sa force en 2007 la force de sa campagne
en 2007 et qu'on a peut-être pas réussi
complètement a exprimé à rendre visible
en 2012 mais qui était toujours là pour
moi nicolas sarkozy c'est ça c'est une
synthèse et d'ailleurs pour revenir sur
votre question ce dont l'ump souffre
aujourd'hui c'est de cette difficulté à
refaire synthèse nicolas sarkozy faisait
la synthèse idéologie sur tout ce qui se
discute en ce moment était derrière
nicolas sarkozy
il faisait synthèse entre des
sensibilités qui il est vrai sont
différentes ça c'est l'adn de l'ump
l'adn de l'ump c'est d'avoir les
sensibilités différentes mais salouël sa
force c'est sa force
si on sait en faire la synthèse et sa
faiblesse ça devient des divisions voilà
c'est ça qu'on est en train de vivre
aussi
j'en reviens à patrick buisson puisqu'il
parlait ce matin il parle peu il est
interviewé dans une radio ce matin il va
lui y voit lui une réelle fracture à
l'ump entre les militants et les
parlementaires
vous la sentez vous cette fracture
c'est à dire finalement entre la base et
ceux qui sont témoins pour moi la
légitimité en politique elle procède de
l'élection ce qui a deux conséquences
d'abord si on veut durablement par les
politiques et s'investir dans la vie
politique il faut passer par l'élection
l'élection et ceci s'adresse à tous ceux
qui souhaitent participer il sait les
garçons de la vie politique et ensuite à
l'intérieur d'un parti à l'inter de
l'institution c'est la même chose les
parlementaires ils ont sont légitimes
parce qu'ils sont élus les
parlementaires et sont légitimes parce
qu'au mois de juin il n'était pas en
train de commenter les faits et gestes
des uns les autres
il était en train de se battre sur le
terrain pour se faire élire dans des
circonstances qui était particulièrement
difficile parce que vous savez une
élection législative dans la foulée
l'élection présidentielle et d'une
défaite à l'élection présidentielle
elle est difficile après l'élection
présidentielle il y en avait qui on peut
prendre quelques repos ou faire des
commentaires et puis on a d'autres qui
sont tournés tout de suite cela sièges
qui se sont battus dans des conditions
qui n'étaient pas faciles où je prétends
que cela ils ont une légitimité
supérieure aux autres pour parler au nom
des français et pour parler au nom de
mi-temps qui se battait avec les autres
voilà voilà pour le gourou qu'ils se
taisent d'autres d'autres sujets
d'actualité notamment valérie très
valeur qui a annoncé qu'elle serait le
témoin d'un mariage gay dès que la loi
sera votée est ce qu'elle est dans son
rôle lorsqu'elle fait ce genre de
déclarations c'est si elle est le témoin
d'un mariage à titre personnel et amical
si c'est un acte politique et qu'elle
est en train de de témoigner d'un
soutien à un projet politique à ce
moment là elle fait de la politique
et moi je dis ça peut être un choix mais
c'est pas cohérent avec ce que nous a
dit à trois mois il ya trois mois valait
travail leur a dit après l'histoire du
tweet j'arrête je ferai plus de
politique
on va fa si c'est pour participer à
titre personnel mais là ça ressemble
dans la manière dont vous lis tu as une
prise de position politique c'est autre
chose
est-ce que vous même vous participerez à
la manifestation du 13 janvier prochain
contre le projet de loi qui va arriver
devant le parlement
manifestation que soutient jean françois
copé y siens alors moi sur le mariage
gay moi je suis pas opposé à ce qu'on
améliore les conditions l'union entre
les couples homosexuels parce que je
vois bien que la signature du pacs au
greffe du tribunal c'est pas
satisfaisant amélioré qui est qu'il ya
des problèmes concrets qui se pose en
revanche je suis pas favorable à
l'adoption et singulièrement sur la
question d'adoption à ce qu'on bouscule
les conditions d'affiliation et donc je
suis prête à participer à toute
initiative dont les slogans sur ce sujet
sont claires et d'ailleurs c'était son
slogan dans les camps dans les
manifestations et les fesses bah oui
manifestation qui a eu la récemment sur
le sujet il ya eu deux manifestations -
il y en a une dans le slogan j'ai trouvé
était était bien choisie je peux y
adhérer ce que j'ai vu c'était un papa
et une maman ou non pas aux enfants
et c'est vrai que je trouve qu elle
expliqué aux enfants qu'ils avaient
pensé des prestations dont les slogans
ne me convenait pas si c'est au mois de
janvier la fusion de ces deux troupes de
choses là je suis pas d'accord si on
reste bien clairement sur ce que j'ai
décrit comme position pourquoi pas elle
est députée verts ont déposé une
proposition de loi pour interdire
totalement
l'exploration et l'exploitation des gaz
de schiste l'ascap à la une par un peu
d'obscurantisme de la part des verts
fermer définitivement la porte à
l'exploitation en france des gaz de
schiste nous avions fait voter une loi
pour interdire la fracturation
hydraulique pour explorer et exploiter
les gaz de schiste et je crois que cette
loi est est sage et constitue un bon
équilibre
pourquoi je prends deux minutes pour
pour l'expliquer je crois que ça va
dominer alors je le fais rapidement
c'est pas le gaz de schiste en lui-même
comme produit qui pose problème
la molécule gaz de schiste est une
molécule de gaz c'est la même que celle
que vous importez par métallier
d'ailleurs quand on à l'export on entend
expression gaz de schiste suis sûr que
beaucoup de nos concitoyens pensent que
c'est un gars différent non c'est un
saint gaz qui est dans une roche
différentes qu'on va chercher d'une
manière différente
donc le problème ce n'est pas le pro
d'exploitation le problème c'est la
manière dont on va le chercher c'est la
méthode si un jour on trouvait une
méthode propre et qu on était à 1
période de notre histoire où on continue
à importer du gaz bien sûr un jour ce
serait bien de se passer d'énergie
fossile mais aujourd'hui on continue à
importer du gaz ont produit au niveau
national plutôt de l'importer si on peut
le faire de manière propre pourquoi pas
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui la seule technique qui
existent pour exploiter explorer gaz de
schiste c'est la technique de la
fracturation hydraulique vis-à-vis de
l'impact environnemental de laquelle
nous avons les plus grands doutes parce
que l'expérience nord américaine n'a pas
jusqu'à ce stade était très concluante
moi je pense que la loi que nous avons
fait et équilibrée elle condamne pas le
produit caisse de chez lui même ce
serait absurde encore une fois ces mêmes
gaz que celui qu'on importe que celui
que vous consommez elle compte pas le
condamne à la demande
vous soutenez françois hollande contre
les écologistes qui a ouvert la porte
aux recherches
oui il a dit un truc très surprenant il
a dit que de chercher à l'autre jour il
a dit
keane qui ne ferait pas de fracturation
hydraulique
oui enfin quand il a dit ça il a dit
qu'il allait appliquer la loi que nous
avons fait voter et que les socialistes
n'avaient pas voté je vais vous dire un
c'est une bonne nouvelle que le
président de la république nous disent
qu'il va appliquer la loi on est
contents d'eux ça aurait été mieux dans
ce cas là s'il était d'accord
si les députés socialistes à l'époque
avait pu s'y associer non mais les mais
de là à interdire totalement et la
recherche et l'exploitation comme le
veulent les et fier jeu s'en
trouve écornée si un jour on trouve un
système d'exploration et d'exploitation
j'ai propre et si c'est un moment de
notre histoire où ne sont pas
désintoxiquer complètement de l'énergie
fossile et donc où on importe encore
plutôt que d'en apporter en produire ce
serait pas absurde si vous voulez ça
n'est pas le cas alors que 2 6 1 quand
même pour affirmer cette position on
vous a compris on accourt pays ont
laissé la porte ouverte à la recherche
pour pouvoir y joly fait la même micro
mouvements fusée moi j'ai une petite
formation si je vois là c'est la même en
le punissant ainsi donc il n'y a pas à
être contre le produit jeudi sur orbite
en matière scientifique avec vous merci
beaucoup nathalie que c'est ce que marc
ysaye d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
merci père et la semaine prochaine a mis
sauna santé marisol touraine sera notre
invité bonsoir a très vite
à chaussures sacs et pauvres 46 % des
jeunes non diplômés sont au chômage ce
sont les chiffres noirs publié cette
semaine mais qu'en est-il d'une jeunesse
un peu particulière d'une jeunesse dont
on parle assez peu qui est discrète et
travailleuses une jeunesse rurale et
agricole une jeunesse en jachère c'est
le thème du docu et du débat de la
semaine sur public sénat le débat
présenté par benoît duquesne dimanche à
10h sur public sénat
casse-cou en caisse caisse comme
toujours vous qu'est ce qu'on va manger
du poulet qui n'a pas un très mauvais
souvenir de la continuer son enfance
les choses changent évoluent ici à lons
le saunier le défi chaque jour cuisine
et 5000 repas à base de produits frais
locaux et blu ray cuisine municipale de
bon matin s'apparente à une fourmilière
bonjour bonjour vous êtes directeur de
la cuisine centrale et c'est ici que
tout se passe ah oui là on est en plein
coeur de la pâtisserie mais on a
d'autres pièces on va aller voir un
petit peu ce qui se fabrique chez nous
allez c'est parti
didier fait mener le monsieur
restauration collective est à la tête
d'une batterie d'employés 56 au total
et comme dans une entreprise il a une
obligation de résultat
ici le groupe
on s'est remis en cause au niveau de
notre habitation c'est dire qu'on sait
on a réfléchi comment cuisiner plus
intelligemment avec moins de pertes avec
un meilleur goût et avec on va jusqu'au
bout à l'assiette du consommateur on l'a
vérifié que ce qu'on lui sert n'est pas
trop trop trop chargé voilà ce qu'est
pas de déchets pas de gaspi leur slogan
du bio dont un prix raisonnable mais sur
bonjour les jeux nous montrer le boeuf
les objectifs sont ambitieux les astuces
nombreuses donc là on est sur une
cuisson de boeuf qui va cuire pendant 18
heures à basse température
ça va nous donner demain matin ça va
nous donner ça ça c'est celui qui accuse
cette nuit donc on est sur un boeuf qui
a et sur le gain n'a pas besoin
d'utiliser de couteau deux fourchettes
où on peut le manger à la cuillère ça
donne un confit ça nous donne un boeuf
qui est tendre et qui garde son jus à
l'intérieur une cuisson longue havas
températures la nuit pour des économies
d'énergie mais la réflexion ne s'arrête
pas là tout est pensé en termes d'impact
sur l'environnement pour les emballages
plusieurs pistes sont à l'étude même les
plus improbables ont remplacé la
classique barquettes en plastique ont
réfléchi sur deux choses la première
c'est le remplacement de cette marque
est par un autre produit en laisse et
l'amidon de maïs en effet la pulpe est
le cas la sucrière est aujourd'hui
correspond à notre besoin
après on a déjà un fournisseur local qui
travaille sur la marque et de bois par
exemple avec qui nous prennent qui nous
permettait de travailler avec un produit
local en corse et qui est jusqu aux
clients du local du local et encore du
local et si c'est bio c'est encore mieux
de la fourche à la fourchette du champ à
la table didier piste s'est produit
alors les dans la chambre froide des
primeurs on va trouver à la fois des
produits qui viennent du territoire
national et des produits qui sont bio
alors elle a donc
bio qu'est ce qui n'est pas bio tout ce
qui est local et bio non
les carottes les betteraves les choux
pointu les courgettes le céleri et les
autres là la fin de courgettes tout ça
c'est du bio les coges voilà après bien
entendu les oranje dans le jura c'est
pas pour demain
non mais il ya bien d'autres choses
produites dans le jura est depuis 2006
la viande de boeuf servi et 100 % bio il
a fallu développer des partenariats
montée des filières avec les producteurs
éleveurs agriculteurs du coin entre
didier et francis le producteur bovin
les clés de la réussite une relation de
confiance sans intermédiaire on
travaille pas il définit si son travail
du gestionnaire principal souci c'est de
boucler leur budget d'avoir des repas
qu'ils soient au niveau tarif que ce
soit raisonnable que ça passe pour les
gamins passent pour les ouvriers que ça
passe pour tout le monde
quand je dis qu'ils ont trahi par des
financiers bas c'est un peu l'habitude
qu'on avait jusqu'à maintenant milieu
paysan
puis c'est encore ce qui existera encore
longtemps
eh ben c'est de travailler avec des gens
qui font de l'argent sur notre dos là
c'est pas tout à fait le cas
d'ailleurs juste équilibre le producteur
rien de sa vie eux ils arrivent à bien
valorisé derrière faille valorise bien
ils ont un bon produit un prix
raisonnable et tout le monde est content
la ville fournit chaque trimestre au
producteur un plan de consommation ce
qui leur assure une sécurité financière
très concrètement on va leur donner pour
dans trois mois le nombre de vaches qui
vont avoir à battre à préparer et
l'abattage qu'on va qui va avoir lieu
début d'année prochaine
les vaches du coin sont des laitières
alors comment les transformer en vaches
à viande on les laisse paître
tranquillement durant trois mois avant
le départ pour l'abattoir
c'est l'une des exigences inscrites dans
le cahier des charges conclue entre la
ville et les paysans
il ya différents il ya différents
niveaux ont déjà ça soit des
montbéliardes dans un premier temps donc
une race locale et les races locales des
vaches de réforme vaches de réforme
montbéliarde donc des vaches qui ne
doivent pas aurore plus de huit ans
d'âge ou alors qu'elle ait fait un
maximum de 5 euros en clair
l'exploitation doit être bio à bannir
donc les engrais chimiques les
désherbants ce cargo gicler bête et 100%
naturel et puis il y as sans doute ce
petit quelque chose en plus francis est
fou de ses vaches
alors comment vous les appelez vos
vaches elles ont toutes un nom et je
connais leur nom par coeur tout sur les
imac 72 donc ça va
les liens revient bien être via et tu
vois l on veut avoir à boire aux prix et
mais y'a un vague de chaque côté ils
vont à chaque fois et crac par dessus la
barrière